Samuel leaves here and in this video
we're going to be talking about serviced
accommodation and how you can
potentially double triple or even
quadruple your return on investment
through renting your properties out on
serviced accommodation so first some of
you interested in stay tuned so thanks
for coming on the show Russell you're
fabulous I know you've got a lot of
experience in service accommodation we
do some pretty big deals together at the
moment yeah we're gonna be renting out
the four apartments that we've just
we've just bought service accommodation
we've got a couple of other title splits
that we're gonna be doing the service
accommodation the castle we're gonna
rent out a service accommodation what is
serviced accommodation so in the best
way to describe it is basically a it's
like a hotel but without having to have
staff sure so a hotel without staff
meanly what the people just have a short
stay there yeah so typically short stay
I mean sometimes it can be slightly
longer but it's always short short stays
a night a few nights yeah yeah some
people might need it for a few months
but yes so so generally speaking service
accommodations when people come they
stay for a few nights maybe they're on
vacation maybe they're in between houses
yeah well it's not any business
businesses that is people that use it
the most yeah so people are traveling
for business or builders that are doing
a project somewhere yeah
like saying a relocation and tourists as
well so that's great so a couple
questions number one is is it a lot of
hard work managing a serviced
accommodation house kind of like a
misconception that you've got single
debts which are the easiest then you got
HMOs and then you've got service
combination but in many ways they're
easier to manage with I hate you right
what how are they easier to manage them
I mean an HMO isn't that difficult if
you've got a good height to my manager
well then you're not managing it that I
yeah no that's true that's true but it
all comes down to systems that because
yeah of course so so why do you think
people say serviced accommodation is
really difficult and why is it not I
think they think it's difficult for a
few reasons first of all is
they're looking at you thinking you've
got a continual turnover of people yeah
which means you're gonna be happy to
continue to find new people and
continually let new people in yeah
that's the first reason and what I would
say to that is yes you do but you don't
really do the work because you're gonna
just advertise it on places are booking
calm air B&B tamago late rooms all those
websites and then you're gonna have to
individually put it on all these
different sites so well you could do or
or you could just use a like an art
online like that like a vivo vivo
which is a lifesaver yeah which we made
you put it on there and it puts it on
all the other sites yeah okay so you put
it on a vivo it then promotes it on all
the sites yeah all the sites that you
choose I mean obviously some of them got
different guidelines some people say
that you know you should run in service
accommodation advertise yourself and
they should go and put postcards and all
that stuff what do you think of that I
think it's rubbish why why because
booking.com I might think it's slightly
off here but it's something like they
spent 200 million a day on advertising
Wow
I don't know if that's true but
certainly in the millions do you think
you could compete with that one and the
other thing is is I think stupid they
put them in local magazines all right
let's say you would go into business in
Oxford would you be like I'll before I
go let me drive there get one there
little magazines of course you are
everything's online now it's similar to
HMOs you're gonna put HMOs on certain
websites you're gonna put them on like
spare room it is what what 90% of
bookings and the rooms get filled from
spare room not far off yeah same with
service accommodation you were going to
get most of it from booking comm maybe
some from air B&B but that's that's
gonna run all through a vevo so how do
you what I love about it though it was
with HMOs when someone thinks I think I
might move there what you gonna do
you've got a well you'll manage your
house to go and let the noone make the
appointment and the appointment
have them not turn up May yeah show them
around for them to decide whether or not
them oh this combination you take the
money up front they booked online
themselves through booking comm or
whatever no agent needed for that no and
then as long as you've got like a key
safe or what you need right Oh what it
always shocks me occasionally when when
we're we're not when I stay away cuz I
always like to use service commerce yeah
check out the competition and then
sometimes they come and let me in
themselves and you thinking you just
wasted like an hour of your life because
you because you didn't invest in a 15
pound key master from Argos it's crazy
isn't it yeah and also I don't know this
is just me but I actually don't really
want to meet them no I don't want to
meet them especially when you're
arriving late I just want to get my room
oh if you're staying at a at an air B&B
or you know you know in a mini hotel
sometimes I had it when I was in London
and I booked
I booked a few nights at a hotel and
they didn't do what they couldn't do my
last date try to find another hotel and
I booked it and I got there and it was
the most disgusting like it was really
cheap to be fair because I was in a rush
and I've been at this expensive hotel I
thought I you know what I'm only gonna
be sleeping there I think it was like 50
pounds or something in London but I got
there it was a disgusting house really
gross and when I got there I was
thinking well this is a house not a
hotel and there was a note on the door
and then I said call this number and
I'll come and let you in and I thought
wow how unprofessional but you know fair
enough he was hammering so I called this
number and I waited 45 minutes outside
in the rain in London with two or three
other people who were also outside
waiting in the rain getting really
frustrated so then finally we go inside
at the house after wait this guy comes
like rushing walking rushing so I don't
like this obviously come from work or
whatever he's stressed we're fed up he
lets us in and I'm thinking you know ah
at least I'm in now and I'm sure it's
gonna be really nice on the inside I
walk in man it is a disgrace I go into
my bedroom there the bedroom is a good
size as well as a good size there's a
mattress on the floor that's yellow and
I can see we stains on the mattress
actually stains on the mattress did you
stay there you actually stay well I have
a choice now I'm also starving because
I've had to wait 45 minutes and I'm
hungry and now it's getting a night and
I'm tired
it's about nine ten o'clock at night and
I think this is disgusting so I'm like
on my phone we've no Wi-Fi with bad 3G s
trying to find another hotel to stay at
and then in the end I think you know I'm
not sleeping at mattress I'm just gonna
sleep on the floor with no duvet because
the dudes there wasn't even a bed it was
just a mattress it was just a mattress
on the floor so I sleep on the floor and
I'm thinking this is absolutely
disgusting and also the house like it
was it was just horrible so I don't know
what do you think about that but I think
that serviced accommodation horrible
sketchy typically no I mean typically no
key safer I know I imagine if you looked
up a review for that place the views
would be terrible yeah yeah maybe I
should have done maybe sure tonight I
don't remember I just all I remember is
the we stains
that's terrible so so what do you a
service accommodation properties look
like well the two most important things
for me
well three most important things for
some when they arrived they want
well they want a bed but I would have
thought that was a given no we stand
nobody stains on the bed number one yeah
obviously how did that happen
they obviously didn't have a cleaner and
they were gone so no one move on is you
want to be really clean yeah and you do
that by having cleaners yeah every
single day
it depends every single if you've got
like like on our larger ones where we've
got like seven eight rooms and it very
much is like a like a B&B I suppose but
we've looked about the breakfast yeah
yeah you want them in every day because
you got people moving in and out yeah if
you've got an apartment then we I just
do on arrival and
leaving sure I don't I think if you got
an apartment you don't expect someone to
come in and clean for you well you know
maybe if you were staying for longer
maybe you were okay but yeah second
thing is are really clean you want
really good Wi-Fi yeah get me you didn't
have now people expect Wi-Fi it's also
nice if you can put things like Smart
TVs and stuff so people go yeah and and
how important are reviews reviews are
the live BRE WI reviews are everything
because of course you never book a
property to stay another night without
reading the replace yourself when you're
looking at a place you scroll through
looking for the one stars that yeah yeah
well what somewhere a lot like the local
Indian near me I really like it I love
it yeah I looked it up live Adair so
awesome was getting at one star if you
know I was like reading it yeah I've got
experience going to this place I've used
it like 10 times always been brilliant
I'm still scrolling through there once
no honey I wish I'd done it before I
went to my tomorrow one yeah so be an
idiot some of us some of our students as
well that have gone on to do service
accommodation I've really amazed how
easy it really is
well the beautiful thing is is that it
works well with you've got money if you
haven't got money because yeah we'll get
there in a minute
we'll get there in a minute but the
actual management side of it yeah oh yes
sorry so first thing management I forgot
we talked about that so you've got your
booking system which people obviously
gonna do yeah you need to organize
cleaners and they they can do everything
for you really yes they can do other
things like making sure the fire alarms
for you they can make sure if they're
specially getting regularly they so
basically we have a checklist of what
needs to be done cleaners this that the
other what the cleaners need to do yeah
cleaners are basically the only people
that really we need to employ jay-z
you also use them as freelancers
regulate you might have a maintenance
person as well yeah cool because it's
worth spending the money on keeping it
top dollar
rather than you cannot skinflint a
serviced accommodation property you just
can't you want to get it top dollar so I
think you need on Suites turn out
beautifully on suite rooms absolutely go
to town on it even if you have to spend
like 10 15 grand getting it up and
running or whatever you have to spend
just do it really really nice so you
walk in and it feels like a hotel yeah
and if you can already buy or some
goodies
fine if you're already renting as a
renter matching the condition fine but
trying to do a service accommodation
like on the cheap he's not really gonna
work however we're going to get down in
a bit of how you can start with no
moment yeah we're gonna get there I
would say that I don't think you have to
have absolutely right we expensive stuff
I don't think needs to be fresh nice
clean you need to walk in and think I
could sleep here yeah one of the ladies
you know I think you know they don't
talk about Cameron the kruskal's went to
that whole room oh yes yeah she came on
the crash course heard it would do and
she thought sounds tacones no I'm gonna
try it out with the room that I have a
spare room in my house she's got a high
mortgage she's living with a partner she
rents out her own room and if she'd have
rent it out as a HMO room she might have
got farming to plan a month since
combination she's getting a hundred
pounds and night you know the story is
she covering a mortgage coming a
mortgage cover the bills and she's got
money left over yeah and now she's
thinking well why don't I buy another
house in order to rent the whole thing
out on serviced accommodation and just
put a keepsake out the door but she
hasn't got the money to buy a house so
what she's now done is she's just found
a landlord who owns a house that's got
five rooms instead of buying it she's
renting it on a went to rent agreement
where she can then rent the whole thing
out service accommodation it's five
minutes down the road where she lives
and and it's given her a profit and a
monthly profit at which she can now
retire on how do you really retire off
one deal when you do serviced
accommodation and you do it right well
it's every tire was it's a rental rent I
won't retire off it but in terms of
could you literally use that to make
your money from well you could retire
off if you've got a system set up and
you've got cleaners well you could but
it's not it's not forever is it I want
okay alright you would okay you wouldn't
vow never ever to work again necessarily
but how many times can you do that like
Leslie and another lady that came
through at the crash course came on the
crash course she did how many swell
seats got three now she's been being
with us for about four months
yeah but she's got three event events
given how much each about two an RF k
two and a half K she's just the one
that's making a 10k turnover on one
house and in fact if you guys if you're
watching that and you
I hear more about that story of Leslie
there's a link just above my head right
now you can see the figures and check
out the story of how she did that but
why aren't more people doing serviced
accommodation I think I think you know a
lot of people not know a lot of people
are but it's becoming a lot more popular
yeah especially the last few years it's
really it's really taken off I think
it's I think people are probably a bit
scared of doing it yeah but it is I know
you sakes I know you say it's less work
than HMOs and it's easier and everything
like that oh wow I wouldn't say Oh once
it was less well so it's different work
from a German well I think with the
service accommodation if you do it wrong
it could be an absolute nightmare mm-hmm
where is that whereas generally speaking
with property if you do it wrong you
know okay one of the advantages
especially if you're trying to keep it
nice is because you got cleaners going
in regularly it's gonna it's gonna keep
in good condition yeah and they'll pick
up on anything so you know you always
hear the horror stories especially with
live single lettuce actually where
people they're on their own they had it
for years and then you Turpin it trashed
it yeah they move out after ten years
and they're just worn it down yeah
you're not gonna have that because
you're gonna be continually keeping it
dry and that's why I hate your nose we
usually like professionals because of
the same what were your first steps then
to someone that was wanting to do
serviced accommodation and hadn't done
it before or maybe they were thinking of
trying one of their current houses a
serviced accommodation what kind of
advice would you give to them first one
I'll probably say get a knowledge about
it and learn about maybe get down to the
crash course we talked about it at the
crash course and that's all mostly free
so you can come down and learn about and
also although we don't spend hours and
hours on it at the crash course you
literally take any question on this
subject yeah so if anyone's got any
questions they're niggling them you
answer that at the crash course yeah so
get some knowledge to write them what
yeah
try out do it try it yeah I always think
it's a really good idea to have an exit
strategy so rather than thinking this
has to work as a service accommodation
just try it yeah but but we're thinking
in so for instance if you've got a
height you know it's working perfectly
fine as HM oh don't evict all the
tenants now and say from now on we're
gonna do a service accommodation maybe
wait for one tenant to leave and then
try renting that room
serviced accommodation and then if it
works do the whole lot what do you think
maybe I mean the problem with that is
then you're mixing so you you mixing cuz
that if that room is you might get away
of it if it you had like an ensuite room
and stuff you might get away with it but
what would you say that I would say that
its title I would well I would just say
that if you came to imagine you were
staying somewhere even if your room was
nice HMOs they tend to be look very
lived in it doesn't look very hot
so if you go into a room and wait for
the kitchen had all the stuff in there
the bottom line is that work I mean
Airbnb works between week's dining room
someone's the bottom line is is if you
just test it and go through the process
of put in a room or whatever on the
right platform ya see the response even
if you haven't got a room for them and
just set them to another room I don't
know she couldn't really do that but I'm
just thinking just I'm just thinking to
give people confidence to just try it so
Robin thinking they but I spend a lot of
money or they've got a victor whole
house just try it somehow how would you
how would you do that like this she's
trying on her own house yeah which
obviously is a good way to yeah I'd to
start and what idea when I first tried
it was I one of my apartments when it
became vacant I was like right and then
you were like my goodness I'm making
loads of money yeah it's working really
well how much how much do you get per
night for that one that one it's varies
a little bit but it's around its not
great about 80 quid 80 quid and how what
kind of occupancy rate can you expect
for serviced accommodations generally
national average is really high it's
around about eighty percent eighty three
point six yes and I guess that depends
where it is if it's somewhere like
Oxford or Cambridge or editing Brock's
was that Duke got the highest means
erasing me in not in the UK in England
Edinburgh in the UK timber in the UK
Birmingham is pretty good but it was
great though it was good because it you
know we talked earlier about who are
your market and you've got obviously
business people and then you've got
people are traveling for work yeah
that's Birmingham takes those books and
the cool thing what you do on the crash
course is you actually get the computer
up and you show people how to find out
if an area is in high demand or not yeah
by going on the relevant websites and
stuff which is fantastic so now
great okay cool so if you're thinking
about service accommodation and you
interested put your comments below your
questions below also come down to a
crash course and you can pick muscles
brain but as Russell said just try it
try on a small scale test it I always
say for everything plan do review don't
forget to check out Leslie's video where
you'll hear how she became financially
free in three months through rent to
rent serviced accommodation which should
be on the screen in just a moment and
until next time have a great week
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time